that's right it is that time of year
again folks not only is it a time to
just Gorge out on holiday food and mess
around with all the cool Christmas gifts
you got but it's time for me to give you
my list of the top ten best movies of
2013 and just like last year in the year
before that this list is not a review of
movies this is a very biased and
subjective Jeremy John's love the [ __ ]
out of these movies list if for nothing
else arthouse movie goers are going to
hate the first half of this list and
arthouse movie goers are probably going
to hate the second half of this list
also hopefully we'll all just have a lot
of fun here introductions made so let's
get started number 10 coming in at
number 10 is bad grandpa toldja my list
but hey apparently it still has class
bad grandpa was hilarious I love seeing
people get pranked it was elaborate it's
cool being a fly on the wall in the
candid camera kind of situation the fact
his friends know movie in 2013 made me
laugh as hard as I did in bad grandpa
movie like that's gotta make the list
good night
coming in at number 9 was a movie that
was actually a lot higher up on the list
and then more movies came out but it's
still on the list Star Trek ended
darkness I'm a big Star Trek fan I'm a
big Cumberbatch fan makes the two
together you have star trek into
darkness which is also great for me
Cumberbatch was a badass I love what
Kirk has to go through I love the
parallels this movie has with certain
other Star Trek movies the first Abram
Star Trek movie was great for movie
goers in general star trek into darkness
was a Star Trek movie made for Star Trek
fans I am a Star Trek fan dug the [ __ ]
out of it number eight coming in at
number eight was Power Rangers for
grown-ups that's right Pacific Rim I
went into this movie wanting one simple
thing I want to say huge robots fight
big monsters guess what I got exactly
that I had so much fun with this movie
this movie knew exactly what it was
delivered exactly what I wanted I just
got two puppies not too long ago
I enjoyed the [ __ ] out of Pacific Rim so
much I actually named them [ __ ] and
danger sea Gypsy and danger say hi it's
the world they're not impressed
yeah this movie was badass number seven
yeah I love sci-fi it's no secret
when you have sci-fi done by a director
who can make sci-fi good you simply have
what Neill Blomkamp does with sci-fi
movies and so we have Elysium I liked
Elysium style
I liked Elysium is great I liked the
entire situation of what is
happening in Elysium and I loved the
[ __ ] out of Charlotte Oh Coakley in his
movie number 6 you know what number 6
could really use a solid rivalry in some
high-octane racing that's right we got
rush rush was really cool Ron Howard
does tension really well between
characters you got these two guys racing
the rivals they're racing for different
reasons in their lives you want to root
for them both what to do I don't know
just enjoy this [ __ ] out of the movie
that's a good start I enjoyed rush after
I watched it I was like probably gonna
be on the list hey it is funny how life
works
number 5 yep wolf of Wall Street gotta
be on here why not only because the
characters who have so much fun in the
movie are played by really good actors
but in terms of script the wolf of Wall
Street had the best dialogue of any
movie I saw a year people in this movie
are maniacs to animals whatever the case
it makes the movie really fun to watch
telling if American Psycho played the
stock market and didn't kill anybody
wolf of Wall Street now we're getting
down to it this last four you know they
hit me where I live number four number
four took my childhood and reminded me
why my childhood was really awesome
saving mr. banks a really heartfelt peek
behind the curtain of how Mary Poppins
got adapted to the big screen great
actors in the movie great moments in the
movement seemed in this movie Heather
came up with the iconic Mary Poppins
music is like it's like watching
Michelangelo paint the Sistine Chapel
watch this movie and the next three
movies in this list these are the
necessities friends but three all right
coming at number three there's no
denying it I'm a middle-earth fanboy The
Hobbit was badass why would it not be on
the list I have no idea so hey it's on
the list the hobbit the desolation of
smiled was fun it was entertaining it
was badass Smaug is the greatest dragon
ever put in a movie ever in the history
of cinema and I was alive to see that in
2013 all I know is desolation of smaug
simply did not make number one because
there were two other movies in 2013 that
hit me like a heart phone and they are
this is the movie I'm going to remember
for a very long time and by a long time
I mean years of my life
it is this decade Schindler's List and
it is 12 years of slave you walk away
from this movie you drive home in dead
silence you think about this movie for
days nights weekends holidays it's
tragic it's powerful point is it's
really good if you haven't seen it by
now you're doing yourself a disservice
go watch 12 years of slave and also
watch nobo 1 this is it this is number 1
this is the movie this transported me
into space gravity I saw gravity on a
weekend every weekend after that I saw
more movies and every weekend after that
I assess how much I like gravity is it
still number one for 2013 the answer
every weekend was absolutely this movie
was intense you feel alone you feel for
Sandra Bullock's character it's a fight
for a life you would swear to God Danny
Boyle directed this movement in the
vacuum of space it is certain death up
there center but looks like I'm gonna
fight to survive there was no noise when
everything is getting rekt by de bridge
just like it freaked me out I've always
been a space fanatic this was the most
accurate representation of space it's
not even outer space space space earth
orbit space what is I wanted to watch
this movie again immediately after I
left the movie theater gravity great job
you hooked me you have been my number
one movie of 2013 since I saw you and
that friends if you're still around
means I guess you care about my top 10
list it's my list of top 10 best movies
of 2013 and yes absolutely there is
going to be a list of the top 10 worst
movies of 2013 per my opinion that's
coming soon in the meantime thank you
for checking out my top 10 best movies
of 2013 and if you watch this video for
validation on what you liked and you
ended up hating everything on this list
I'm sorry to hear that but hey what fun
is the world if we can't have a
differing opinion alright so your top 10
favorite movies of 2013 what are they
whatever they are comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
you